So I know I don't mention this often, but
this is a viewer and listener supported program.
I would love for you to become a member of
the David Pakman show by signing up at Join
Pakman dot com.
It is very cheap and we do a daily extra program
just for our members.
You can sign up at join Pakman Dotcom and
you can use the coupon code fresh start all
one word, all lowercase fresh start to save
a bundle off of the membership of your choice
at Join Pakman dot com.
I noticed some funny posts this morning on
the David Pakman show sub Reddit.
Of course you can join nearly 26000 of our
viewers and listeners at David Pakman dotcom
slash Reddit.
There is a very funny post that is a screenshot
of OCN and is one americanus.
This is the alternative to Fox News that Donald
Trump has been recommending.
They are even crazier and they put up a delusional
map of what they say is the real electoral
map from this election.
And it has done it has Donald Trump with four
410 electoral votes.
And the headline is Reports Seized SeeWhy
T.L.
Data Shows Landslide Win for President Trump.
So they're going to be very, very disappointed
on January 20th.
But that is what Donald Trump is recommending.
Newsmax and OCN are the recommended alternatives
to Fox News that Trump is pushing people towards.
Also, a post reminding us that, yes, 87 year
old Republican Senator Chuck Grassley has
tested positive for coronavirus.
Now, you might remember there was this absolutely
surreal picture or even might have been video
or certainly pictures of a shortly after the
super spreader event, which led to there was
that short period of time where a bunch of
Republicans got the virus, including Donald
Trump, Senator Ron Johnson, Senator Mike Lee.
Within days of being diagnosed with the virus,
there was a Senate hearing at which Mike Lee,
who who was covid positive, was standing above
87 year old Republican Senator Chuck Grassley
at a Senate hearing with no mask talking to
someone.
It might have been Lindsey Graham or somebody
else.
And we looked and said, how does how does
Chuck Grassley, if this is what's going on,
how the hell does Chuck Grassley avoid getting
coronavirus?
And indeed, 87 year old Chuck Grassley now
has coronavirus.
Of course, I never wish illness nor death
on anybody.
Statistically speaking, Chuck Grassley is
at quite high risk.
At the same time as a senator, he has access
to very, very good health care.
And much like Donald Trump got access to things
which the average person would not have access
to, it's certainly conceivable Chuck Grassley
would get the same.
And as we know, the level of care that one
receives can make a major, major difference
in whether who there is.
There's actually this crazy story of a covered
ICU where one person, they were so overloaded
that nursing and medical attention was extremely
limited.
But there was one patient in there that was
the wife of a doctor that worked in that hospital.
She was designated a so-called VIP.
And for a short period of time, she was the
one serious covid patient that survived.
So understand that health access to health
care disparities make a major, major difference
when fighting with a lot of conditions.
It's not just coronavirus.
Chuck Grassley with Coronavirus joined the
discussion at David Pakman dot com slash redit